a body broker is the person that takes
their body processes it and sends that
body where it needs to go and before you
say gross there is no way I'm doing this
know that for every body you collect you
can sell them for at least five thousand
dollars now do I have your attention and
you don't even need any special licenses
or equipment to do it all you need is a
strong stomach and the right connections
how easy is it for someone to enter
do you have a Sawzall
you have a garage a person with no
medical experience no funeral director's
license was able to open up a whole body
donation program take possession of a
human body dismember it send it
throughout the nation without any type
of Licensing oversight it's harder to
sell hot dogs on a cart than it is to
get in this business this is the
gruesome yet profitable business of body
brokers
[Music]